the pop star is starting 2022 with a
bang as she revealed a new residency
it's going to be at caesar's palace i
think i should help her carry all these
this is a lot to handle it's called
weekends with adele christian kostarus
live in studio with more on what this
means and how to get tickets yeah that's
the question everyone is asking so the
residency is called weekends with adele
and that's exactly what this is all
about the pop star is scheduled to
perform two shows each weekend starting
on friday january 21st through april
16th now the residency announcement was
made today on her website which will
take place at the coliseum at caesar's
palace
social media as you can imagine exploded
with fans reacting to the news as the
singer recently released her fourth
studio album titled 30
two weeks ago now we mentioned that the
residency is called weekends with adele
and for those 12 weekend performances
well you can imagine tickets will be
limited so we checked out
ticketmaster.com
and this is what we got so pre-sale
tickets will be available through a
registration using ticketmaster verified
fan over here and aft and basically you
can start doing that starting today
through thursday now after you do that
step well fans will receive a code and
we're told that code will give you the
chance to purchase tickets for the
performances on a first come first serve
base but there is only a
max that you can buy each person can get
from one to four tickets so brian denise
ted and i if i get those tickets we're
all going all right remember the demand
for the ticket is expected to be high so
if the demand from the verified fans
exceeds supply well there will not be a
public sale so no details yet as to how
much
these tickets will cost but we can only
speculate that they will be similar to
other strip performances uh residencies
i should say like katy perry and carrie
underwood